[Music]
in false alarm news oh you're just
kidding submitted by spit at 16 Joe oh
my god I sounded like a no how about two
bars
how about 16 bars of this no you see
what you guys did do you ever an old my
ears are bleeding I hope yours are
teeming a migraine are you doing
Careless Whisper
yeah but I forgot the notes you're not
the only one growing our bad
they sound cloud wraps on my land teen
in jail for a decade what a rap song
what was he like yeah but all nerds our
faith doesn't know that yeah I [ __ ]
brought the old lady took her money and
then I slapped on the head like that
yeah I thought you couldn't because it's
entertainment yeah all the Pens well
maybe he's saying something very
specific
Oh ABC News yesterday 5:00 p.m. that was
me
like that kid pilsky in the supermarket
when I robbed it yeah got me on the
[ __ ] surveillance watch it again
it's in my face watch it watch it
yeah mr. news at 7 p.m. yep that's me I
specifically shaved my beard that day so
it didn't look like me what it is Hey
yes this kid his name is Michael Schmidt
Michael motorcycle later likes to stay
Michael de motorcycle ok this is Michael
oh he's about the piece Casey nice that
is against peace actually it says no on
the left a piece on the recipe Oh what
happened was ten days after the Parkland
shooting ha ha you [ __ ] up did he say
he was actually a part of the parkland
shooting
Sookie uploaded this SoundCloud rap
where he he says Ike he didn't think
anyone was watching a SoundCloud or
anyone who even cared about what he was
doing but the title of this
your little [ __ ] at JC HS which is high
school I love you all even though y'all
hurt me and I forgive you I would never
hurt you my broken heart that's a long
title yeah it was like a scream email
rap type of song yeah so for example
some of the lyrics were why were you
mean to me on my Instagram no he said
I'll give you a little extra to hate me
for today he captioned it and then oh he
also sent a tweet that fred hi [ __ ] get
your face booked and then he shared a
link to the rap and then one line of the
song said pull my gun kill your [ __ ]
head now you're dead go to sleep so
because it was titled at the high school
Jack we also sounds like a threat yeah
and so that day when he posted it the
school was gonna have like some sort of
fair or like a an event where there was
a lot of people there yeah and what the
ended up doing is they put the school on
lockdown
they cancelled that event and they
arrested him later on that day because
of that awful ruin the whole entire day
there's so many other people that do
like way worse [ __ ] and they don't find
him until like after something happened
and then they for some reason they
caught this dude yeah well another thing
too is because of the photo that he he
uploaded his soundcloud with it's the
thing that caught him early huh it's
this photo here so good he was claiming
that this gun was fake that was plastic
but then later on it turned out that it
was real but they don't have it but it's
like a method I think it's good that
they did this because I remember like
the FBI getting hella flack yeah like
the other shooter having like all these
red flags yeah so I think now they have
to be hyper sensitive and just in case
cuz I imagine you know really I mean I
know artistic expression is important
but why do you really need to write a
song that says I'm gonna shoot you did
yeah like we don't really need that kind
of artistic mean I know there's a line
that can cross but it's like why are
teenagers writing lyrics like that but
then I guess there's so much teenage
angst if you get into that around them
people are gonna be like whoa
priam feet well you can't do that but I
guess just don't specifically target you
know people or whatever cuz then it's
like oh [ __ ] is this real like it can be
at threats we're gonna just be extra
safe about it maybe you're being
artistic go for it but not until we can
figure this out you're guilty
but what they need to do is be a little
bit early 2000s in the rap style and add
metaphorically before they say [ __ ] I
will metaphorically lyrically
[ __ ] kill you metaphorically
lyrically [ __ ] shoot your
brains out school you know like if they
said that it's different it's it's
because you you know that's that's how
that's how you gotta [ __ ] do it you
can't do it real you can't say literally
oh [ __ ]
no seriously no joke I will shoot you
yeah and so he was arrested for creating
a false public alarm which carries a
five to ten year sentence
if you just yell bomb at an airport yeah
you can't do that forever you can't
thank god someone told movie theater
that's good I'm glad I've always been
able to resist him - yeah me too
I don't know you just want to yell some
[ __ ] is way better and way more her
problem that's one man can't really get
mad yellow like starfish there's one of
y'all [ __ ] sometimes you know yeah don't
say Man Overboard on a cruise that's too
many
I like 1 syllables like that's smart you
say please see ya
please yeah but he was just saying that
he's just like you know the weird kid
who loves hip-hop and an over
overwhelmingly white conservative town I
was like I thought hip-hop was like the
cool kids thing like wouldn't be like
you'd the emo kid or something would be
the weird one he thinks he considers emo
rap I think oh okay yeah you don't know
that even plays anymore
hip-hop is so mainstream now you can't
you can't even say [ __ ] like you know
only only black people listen man
there's so many white fans that like
that's one of the biggest reasons why
NWA got famous ass book is because all
the white fans in the Middle America
that were supporting the [ __ ] out of
them just like they're saying Middle
America they love Trump and NWA and
Kanye oh yeah yeah yeah but then he's
just saying like now he's painted as a
school shooter and that he's he's just
really caring himself as a school yeah
he painted himself I mean that's the
that's the label he wanted right I mean
I don't know that's what he wanted that
is because that's like most people are
like oh I'm a drug dealer like Rick Ross
like he's trying to music on another
persona I'm freeway Rick Ross and this
guy is like wall all these drug dealers
and gangsters those personas have been
taken imma assumed the school shooting
pursuit persona and I was getting
trouble for it yeah I mean like what if
I took the persona of Isis Joe and all
my Instagram all I got is I'm like
[ __ ] ak-47 caption kill the infidels
you know I get like mine Adeem homie
like he'll be next to me yeah he's
[ __ ] [ __ ] his nose hairs why are
you dragging me into this [ __ ]
you know every single pictures that and
then you know I'm like flossing my bomb
jacket like I got dynamite every single
pictures my jacket and then one day the
FBI come and [ __ ] swoop me up and
takes me to Guantanamo space and I'm all
screaming like well it was it was I
don't I didn't mean to like it's just a
mad it was on the dream I mean I think
yeah like when you guys said it is
important that they're taking every
threat seriously but then that sucks of
this kid really didn't intend yeah but
with like I always say this like repeat
when people go well you know artistic
and creative expression should always be
whatever whatever right that's true but
as a creator you have to understand that
there are consequences for your actions
you could create hurtful content you
could create whatever but you can't
prevent people from hating you and
wanting to fight you and wanting to
attack you or hating your art or
whatever so if you're gonna claim the
responsibility of an artist then you
gotta be okay with what the [ __ ] is
gonna happen to you yeah because like
when people use freedom of speech to do
like justice or whatever all these
things right and fight against
government they have to take on the
responsibility of government turning on
them yeah they can't be like well no
like I got I'm just creatively
expressing myself but I don't want if I
can be responsible for the content that
I'm making he also wasn't being artistic
he's just being like literal yeah if you
drew a painting and it had a message
embedded in it that's cool but heathrow
I'm gonna shoot this school and text
you're just writing a statement of what
you're gonna do that's not a painting
anymore that's not artistic that's true
[Music]